have you ever been to space I have in
videogames and let me tell you I've done
so many things hell just the other day I
was dogfighting with pirates and Eve
Valkyrie I've destroyed countless craft
and looted the delicious scrap in FTL
and of course engaged in complicated and
nuanced interstellar diplomacy in Mass
Effect big stupid jellyfish but one
thing that has never happened to me ever
in the history of playing space games is
to be turned into a bloody gooey mess of
pulp on the back wall of my spaceship
now I know this may seem like a very
strange thing to mention however not
spending your future as a bloody mess of
gooey pulp is a very real consideration
if the science fiction space travel of
video games we're ever to become science
fact in real life it's all down to
something called inertia inertia you see
is the resistance an object has to a
change in momentum that could be
changing from still to moving or
changing direction while traveling in a
straight line think of being in a car
for example the faster you accelerates
the more force you feel so when you
accelerate in a regular vehicle you go
naught to 60 in eight seconds and the
force you experience you use spirits
some force pushing you into the back of
your seat now say you start accelerating
and then a second later you're traveling
at the speeds you would be had you
jumped off a building the seat that
you're sitting in is equivalent to or
would be traveling at the same speed as
the ground will be rushing up at you you
would just be squished pulp on the back
of your seat nasty so that's what can
happen if you speed up almost
instantaneously but what level of force
can people actually survive what about
real-life astronauts
what do they go through when blasting
off and traveling out through Earth's
atmosphere
so when astronauts take off they feel
this big force pushing down on them
which is a combination of gravity and
inertia which most people know as
g-force though g-force is technically an
acceleration and it's that acceleration
which makes you feel a force so force on
your body of about three to four g which
is enough that they can still move
around and do things as Elizabeth said
we commonly refer to this property of
acceleration as g-force in freefall we
would experience zero-g no gravity at
all standing still we experienced 1g 1
times the force of gravity but as we
start accelerating we experience greater
g-force multiples of the force of
gravity
now as g-force increases so does our
risk of dying it becomes harder to move
your limbs your organs get squashed down
inside your
body and blood gets forced away from
your brain causing you to black out and
eventually perish the body can withstand
low amounts of g-force for extended
periods of time but in some cases we are
also able to handle very high g-force so
long as it's only very briefly back in
the early 1950s Colonel John Paul Stapp
hopped on a rocket sled and find out the
body can handle much much greater loads
for a short time traveling at over 630
miles per hour
he then slowed to a standstill in one
second
pulling an incredible 46.2 G's against
his restraints that's the equivalent of
his body weighing over four tons and you
know what he was fine I mean besides the
broken ribs broken wrists huge blisters
and his retinas detaching from his eyes
fine better maybe but what about
blasting off to Lightspeed almost
instantaneously as is often the case in
games with light speed travel now
ignoring for a minute the technological
hurdles of achieving this speed the
inertia you would feel from that
acceleration wouldn't just turn you into
a pile of bloody pulp in your chair no
no you would be little more than an atom
thick smear on the back wall
okay then but what if we approached that
speed a little slower or maybe a lot
slower say we were to accelerate at 39
meters per second per second a
consistent 4G which modern-day
astronauts experience well at that
velocity it would take around three
months to reach near light speeds and
then of course slowing down would take
the same length of time three months to
speed up and then another three to slow
down that's like eight years now I've
got things to do fortunately though I
might just have an idea what if there
was a force inside your ship pulling you
towards the front at the same rate that
the acceleration is pushing you to the
back effectively cancelling out the
inertia problem well the only force that
could theoretically do this would be
gravity localized entirely inside your
ship easy right James
the idea of creating a localized
gravitational field to offset the force
which you would experience when your
ship is accelerating very quickly is a
nice one because a gravity acts on all
of the particles in your body equally so
as the ship is accelerating you would be
pulled along with the ship and every
part of you would be pulled along with
the same force so the front of you
wouldn't be crushed into the back of you
and so each your front and your back
would be experienced the same force and
so you would not really feel any force
at all however there is no way that we
know of of creating localized
gravitational fields oh well that's a
bit of a bummer fortunately though games
have found a way around this notably
Mass Effect a combination of element
zero and some convenient mass relays
means that while the crew of the
Normandie zip around the galaxy no one
feels a thing except feelings of hot
sexy alien
guess I'm getting pretty good at this so
it's element zero a real thing and could
it reduce our inertia by solving our
mass problem not that kind of problem in
game it works by reducing the mass of
the spaceship and its crew therefore
reducing the inertia of the experience
so could this work as far as we know
there is no way to decrease an object
mass the only way that it might be
possible is if somehow you can
manipulate something called the Higgs
field Higgs bosons got a little press
recently because it just got found at
CERN and it's this thing that gives
objects its mass and if you could
somehow manipulate this Higgs field to
increase or decrease how strongly it's
it's called coupling so how strongly it
interacts well you could possibly change
how that affects an object's mass but
that's very theoretical we have no idea
how to do it okay so it seems a mass
effect can't really help us with our
inertia problem but whatever actual
theoretical physics another way that
people have come up with is rather than
trying to use propellant to just make
you go forward you stay going at a
fairly leisurely speed but you change
space-time around you so you contract
the space in front of you so that even
though you're going at quite a legend
walking pace you're traveling through
less of a distance until you get there
and you look back and actually you've
travelled through a billion kilometers
again how you would actually go about
doing this it's still incredibly
theoretical theoretical it may be but
it's exactly the theory David Braben
crater of the nare 30-year old classic
space simple eat as utilized for his
brand-new kick-started game elite
dangerous what it's doing is it's
compressing the world
so essentially the g-forces are still
not prodigious what it's doing is Dunn's
doing some sort of warping of space in
order to allow it it also means you can
see that the interrelation of the whole
system you know you can see planets you
fly past and actually see it move in
real time and you just see the real
beauty of these systems you know that
the sheer vastness of it and then you
can sort of drop back into sort of
normal space and and realise that you
just realize the vastness of the
distance that you just covered well let
me know what you thought of this week's
reality check and my thanks once again
to James Elizabeth and David for helping
out last week on the show I explored the
science of hardcore fans Gainsbourg
comments are candles 25 said well that
explains the console war and they're
right for more detailed look at the
psychology of console fans check out the
very first episode of reality check are
you a console fanboy for more if you
want to get in touch to me directly
maybe with a comment or to suggest a
topic for reality check best way to do
so is to find me on Twitter at kam fries
Rob and send me a tweet
thanks for watching guys see you next
week